around the globe billions of people
every morning drink from a cup like this
probably you did too one morning okay at
one of us to take a spoon and start
tapping on this cup it seems to emit the
same pitch from all over the place maybe
it is the characteristic pitch of this
cup and if you take another company to
emit another pitch so the music of this
particular cup as it were but then I
thought of tapping somewhere else those
four points emit a higher pitch than
those four points what is going on yes
thank you very much for pointing that
that it has to do the handle but you see
if he has to be behind you need to have
thought that this half of the handle of
the cup near the handle and this half of
the cup father from the handle should
behave differently but that's not how
the symmetry is broken
indeed the point next to the handle and
point farthest from our handle emit
exactly the same pitch where it's 45
degrees off so it's not as simple as
just the present just the handle I
thought about this and thought about
this and this is I think what is going
on in order to understand first why any
four points that form the vertices of
square always emit the same pitch you
know those four point two those four
points will forget about the hand we
pretend that this does not exist and we
will bring it back later
okay so if you talk to sample at this
point you make the cup vibrate just like
so
in response the diametrically opposite
point of the cup can respond in one of
the two ways it can respond this way or
this way but you see the latter of the
two this response is that moving whole
cup back and forth as a whole like a
rigid body and it doesn't change the
shape of the cup but of course it sound
the feminine song has everything to do
the vibration of a body and
changing of the shape so to a good
approximation this response you cannot
hear it doesn't partake in this
production and sound so what you are
hearing is this response of the of the
vibration now the cup on the other hand
as a whole wants to stay in compress but
it doesn't want to change its volume if
you can help it doesn't shrink it does
want to expand so when those two points
go in they push out those two points in
order to compensate and when these two
points go out they pull in those two
points so that as a whole you get this
Los Angeles kind of oscillation which
means that the aiming for a quadruplet
will points that form two vertices a
square sing in unison and now we
understand why those four points singing
some and those four points singing in
unison but why these four points higher
pitch than those four points you know to
understand that
let's bring the handle back you see when
you are exciting one of those four
points it doesn't matter which one they
always sing in unison you have to take
the handle with you because after one of
the vibrating points that touch to the
handle and the filter has to drag the
handle in contrast when you accept one
of those four points you remember how it
works when this causing this goes out
and when this goes in this goes that
unless you can see the point in between
is a note in other words to a good
approximation is not moving so as far as
this quadruple it informant points is
concerned the handle is irrelevant it's
as if it's not there so now you have to
you can imagine two elastic systems in
vibration you can think of them as
Springs made of the same stiffness but
one of them has to drag a heavy handle
and that is this quadruple points and
the other one is that quadruplet
is not attached to any mass the handle
is not there so if you have two Springs
of the same stiffness at one of them
attach the heavy mass and the other one
is not attached the hip mass and you
release them what you expect of course
the Headroom go sluggish three
[Music]
and the right one will go okay and
that's the difference of the pitch that
you hear